how do we find the adjoint of a 3x3
matrix given a 3x3 matrix we need to
find its adjoint let's write it here to
find the adjoint of a we need to find
the matrix of the cofactors of each of
its elements first and then take the
transpose of that matrix so we write the
cofactors of each of these nine elements
here and find the transpose what will be
the cofactor of one it will equal
negative 1 raised to one plus one times
this determinant that will be one
multiplied with three minus ten minus
seven
that's the cofactor of one what's the
cofactor of four it will be negative 1
raised to 1 plus 2 times this
determinant that will equal negative 1
times 0 minus 6 and negative 1 times
negative 6 equals 6 6 is the cofactor of
4 and what is the cofactor of minus 2 it
will equal negative 1 raised to 1 plus 3
multiplied with the determinant of this
that will be 1 multiplied with 0 plus 3
that will equal 3 these are the
cofactors of the corresponding elements
in the first row I want you to pause the
video and find the six remaining
cofactors here this is what you should
have got this will give us the adjoint
of a now how do we find the transpose
here to find the transpose we
interchange the rows and columns the
first row will become the first column
minus 7 6 3 the second row will be
written as the second column 2 3 7 the
third row will be written as 6 negative
2 negative 1 that's the adjoint of a
find the cofactors first and then the
transpose so let me give you an easier
example for this two-by-two matrix B we
need to find its adjoint try it out
okay so maybe you first found the
cofactors and then the transpose but
there is a much simpler way to find the
adjoint of two by two matrices without
really finding the cofactors and the
transpose we can instantly write this as
3 2 minus 5 and minus 1 that's the
answer which you should have got this
will be the adjoint of B but how did I
get it so fast it's very easy first we
interchange the positions of these two
elements notice that 2 3 was written as
3 2 next we change the sign of these two
elements 5 was written as minus 5 and 1
was written as minus 1 this works for
all two-by-two matrices interchange
these two positions and change the signs
of these two elements now with the same
logic why don't you try finding the
adjoint of matrix C we interchange these
2 1 3 can be written as 3 1 we then
change the sign of these two elements
negative 1 will become 1 and 2 will
become negative 2 that's it we have the
adjoint of C interchange these two and
change the sign of these two works for
all two-by-two matrices